now let's jump over to that Joe Rogan
guy because here he is talking about how
the government is going to go out of its
way to regulate everything there will be
new open source sites there will be
sites built to protect Free Speech but
the government the machine is going to
do everything it down and to clamp down
and we don't know as Eric pointed out we
don't know exactly what that will look
like but I think we're starting to get
some hints
if the open source movement does take
hold if people recognize this as being a
real serious threat and start applying
you know just using whatever it is
whether it's mines or the the various
open source social media networks don't
you think the government would somehow
another try to regulate that as well if
they've already got control over
Facebook and Twitter and well that's the
threat so the the threat always is that
they're going to come in and do that and
that that is what they're threatening to
do that there is energy in Washington by
people trying to figure out how to
regulator ban uh open source
having said that banning open source
like interfering at that level carries
consequences with it and so for example
and there are proposals there are
serious proposals from serious people to
do what I'm about to describe do you run
do you run a software program on
everybody's own computer right watching
everything that they do because you have
to make sure that they're not running
software that's supposed to be running
you know do you have basically an agent
built into everybody's chip so that it's
not running you know software that's not
supposed to be running right and then
what do you do when somebody's running
unapproved software you know do you send
somebody to their house to take their
computer away all right so I should have
mentioned before the clip the guy he's
talking to there is an internet Legend
in his own right that's Mark Andreessen
who is a billionaire Tech guy who has
done a gajillion a gajillion site he did
pass on locals by the way but that's
okay uh he's a good guy uh but the point
is even as we decentralize things will
the machine try to figure out how to
take us out why is the machine so
against Bitcoin the idea that I could
store a decentralized some thing of
value and exchange value with you in a
decentralized way that has nothing to do
with the government why is that a threat
to the government well then they don't
get their piece right because they're
basically like the mafia
[Music]
foreign